Now that you've got a handle on visual encodings and
data types, we'd like you to go find your own visualization to decompose it.
Here's what I mean.
This graph shows medals won by each country during the Summer Olympics.
This graphic is actually a cartogram, where the geography, or
the area of each country, has been distorted by the number of medals won.
Larger bubbles indicate a country that's won many medals, like Russia and
China, while smaller countries have won fewer medals, such as Singapore.
For whatever data visualization that you find, I'd like you to indicate what
are the variables, what are the data types, what are their visual encodings and
to what extent are those encodings effective?
You can find eight examples from the link in the instruction notes.
But be sure to find a different graphic than the ones provided here.
We want you to go two steps further, though.
The examples here only describe the encodings for the variables.
Be sure you also identify the data types and
describe the effectiveness of the visual encodings.
Do you think the display analogs aid in the interpretation of the visualization,
or do you think they distract from the viz?
So take some time to find a visualization and answer these questions.
Once you've posted a link or image of the viz with your response in
the discussion thread, check this box to continue.